16:40 in King Charles the first of
England and Scotland his record
Parliament why because his Scottish
subjects were rebelling against his
religious reforms and he needed men and
money to fight them he was hoping that
Parliament would forget the previous 11
years in which he had governed without
them and simply give him the money he
was wrong instead Parliament wanted to
write all of Charles's previous wrongs
against them and so he dissolved it
after only three weeks hence its name
the short parliament the rebelling Scots
called covenant as soon after cross the
English border and occupied these lands
Thomas Wentworth the King's close ally
was to lead the English resistance but
instead the army opted for a different
strategy of running away Charles then
decided to cave in to most of the Scots
demands and also he would pay them to
leave the parts of the north that they'd
seized Charles needed yet more money to
pay them and so once more he had to
recall Parliament he did so hoping that
yet again they simply give him the money
but instead parliament passed some acts
that Charles did not like but given his
weak position could do nothing about
opposition to Charles was led by a man
called John Pym a face Puritan and
believer in the rites of Parliament
Parliament had passed the triennial Act
which meant the Parliament had to be
called at least once every three years
and that this specific Parliament had to
give its consent to be dissolved there
was also the habeas Corpus Act which
meant that the king couldn't arrest him
every pleased anymore furthermore
William Lord the Archbishop of
Canterbury was arrested in Parliament
also had Thomas Wentworth executed for
his previous conduct in Ireland seeing
that Charles was making concessions to
the English and Scottish many Irishmen
were hoping for the same Sam Irish
Nobles led by Phil ammonius east forts
and demanded that the Irish be afforded
similar concessions the Irish populace
rose up shortly afterwards but they were
less interested in concessions are more
interested in kicking the planted
English Protestants out of Ireland for
good
back in England Parliament was still
fighting over how much King Charles was
awful and in late 1641 by a very slim
margin it passed the grand remonstrance
this was basically a list of reasons why
Charles was terrible and that the
previous Church reforms of Lord in the
Irish rebellion were part of a Catholic
plot by 1642 Charles had had enough of
people opposing him and decided to put
an end to it he gathered some soldiers
are marched into Parliament with the
intent of arresting five of its members
the most notable being John Pym these
members had fled before Charles had
arrived and he left Parliament
empty-handed
whilst he failed to arrest those who
deposed him he did manage to do one
thing he convinced everyone that he was
a tyrant as a result Parliament created
the Committee of Safety which promptly
took control of London as well as its
militia and Charles quickly fled the
city both sides started to call
Eliezer made preparations for conflicts
such as when Charles attempted to seize
HoloNet armory but they politely yet
firmly told him to jog on Parliament
declared that Charles was a papist and
wanted to enslave England with the help
of the Irish rebels and Charles warned
the aristocracy the Parliament would
come for them next if the radicals had
their way on the 22nd of August 1642
Charles raised his standard over the
town of Nottingham this is considered by
many to be the formal beginning of the
English Civil War this pitted Charles's
royalist forces known as Cavaliers
against those of Parliament known as the
round heads as the general rule
Parliament had the support of the south
and the east and Charles had the rest
Parliament had much greater access to
money from the largest cities in the
south it also controlled the Navy and
with it trade the king had some support
in Ireland the help of the Scottish
Royalists and had access to much better
commanders the most notable being Prince
Rupert of the Rhine Charles's nephew
from Bohemia Charles assembled his
forces and made straight for London
where he was met by the parliamentary
army led by Robert Devereux the Earl of
Essex at the Battle of Edgehill it was
essentially a tie and after regrouping
Charles did the done what to do next
before resuming his march on London by
this point the Earl of Essex had blocked
the road there and Charles retreated
meaning that this wasn't going to be a
short war throughout 1643 the royalist
forces gained the upper hand the
Parliamentarians did manage to procure
the help of the Scottish Covenanter army
though by promising them lots of cash
the Scottish also wanted assurances that
the Church of England would be modeled
after the Church of Scotland naturally
Parliament was never going to agree to
this and so his leaders hatched a clever
plan they lied the Covenant is were
vital to the parliamentarian cause and
proved their worth in 1644 at the Battle
of Marston Moor it was here that the
royalist army was devastated
particularly by the parliamentarian
cavalry led by a certain Oliver Cromwell
after this defeat the Royalists
basically lost the entire north and York
fell shortly afterwards despite their
success Parliament wanted more and so
ordered the far-reaching reforms be
implemented which led to the creation of
the professional well-equipped new model
army its importance of know here that
not all of the country was happy to be
involved in the Civil War many local
Lords and leaders wanted nothing to do
with it and so assemble with their own
soldiers known as club men to dissuade
either side from coming anywhere near
them 1645 saw the decisive battle of
Naseby which was yet again a crushing
defeat for the Royalists and was
followed up by many more over the next
year
Charles knowing that the war was lost
handed himself over to a Scottish force
in mid 1646 ending the Civil War
Parliament negotiate
with the Scottish to hand over Charles
which they did in 1647 now the
Parliament had chose surely they could
enact the change they wanted right but
no the issue was that Charles was
completely untrustworthy and would
always take the first opportunity to
undo the concessions he'd made
furthermore much of England was getting
riotous due to the tax burden for
funding the army Parliament tried to
disband the army but the army led by Sir
Thomas Fairfax said no which was hard to
argue with because guns this reflects
the fact that political society in
England was becoming increasingly
radical during this period one of the
most extreme groups were the Levellers
who wanted the army to through our
Parliament and create a democratic ie
level society in which all Freeborn men
would be able to vote for accountable
politicians during his captivity Charles
had secretly made a compact with the
Scottish called the engagement which
meant that they would invade England and
restore him with his old powers intact
Charles soon escaped the Scottish
invaded and royalist rebellions broke
out across the country beginning the
second English Civil War this war was a
short one and within a year the New
Model Army had crushed the rebels and
defeated the Scottish army at the Battle
of Preston Charles decided to return to
the negotiating table but the leadership
of the New Model Army known as the
Grandy's weren't interested they saw
Charles as a lying tyrant whose actions
had killed thousands needlessly and that
there would be no worthwhile settlement
whilst he remained in late 1648 some
soldiers commanded by Colonel Thomas
pride stormed Parliament and removed
anyone who disagreed with the Grandy's
in what is known as prides purge the
parliament that was left known as the
rump Parliament opted to put Charles on
trial for high treason he was found
guilty sentenced to death and on the
30th of January 1649 was beheaded at
Whitehall palace shortly afterwards the
Republic was declared called the
Commonwealth of England which was
governed by the rump Parliament in the
Council of State chaired by Cromwell
Parliament and the council didn't really
do much except sell-off royal assets and
lands in order to fund the army to send
it to Ireland the Irish rebels known as
the Irish Confederates were being
supported by English and Scottish
Royalists who had rallied behind Charles
his son also called Charles Cromer was
tasked with the reconquest of Ireland
and with his army of well acquit
veterans made inroads very quickly
he gave the Irish assurances that those
who surrendered would not be harmed but
when he took the towns of Drogheda and
Wexford he promptly slaughtered their
Garrison's and many of the civilians
living there
Cromwell returned to England in 1650 but
the conquest was largely completed in
his absence by 1652
Ireland was completely ransacked during
this invasion and it's estimated that
about 40% of its total population died
between
16:41 and 1652 it was then ordered that
the rebels were to lose their lands and
about 35,000 of them were forced into
indentured servitude and shipped off to
the new world to work on the plantations
they're speaking of the new world most
of the American colonies backed the
royalist side but with great to support
for Cromwell in the north so upon his
return to England Cromwell had to deal
with the Scottish who had received
Charles and proclaimed him as charles ii
of scotland beginning the third english
civil war chromo marched his army north
and crushed a larger force at the Battle
of Dunbar and swiftly occupied Edinburgh
the next year the two met again at
Worcester and yet again Charles lost and
promptly ran away to the continent
ending once and furro the English Civil
Wars by 1653 Cromwell was getting a bit
sick of the rump Parliament and so
dismissed most of its members he then
created a parliament made up of a select
few men who were considered to be deeply
moral in what is known as the Parliament
of the saints or the bare-bones
Parliament this Parliament failed to do
anything and so Cromwell had a
constitution craft it called the
instrument of government which declared
Cromwell to be the Lord Protector of the
Commonwealth of England Scotland and
Ireland that is to say that all three
were now part of the same state meaning
Cromwell with the help of the Scottish
General George Monck could achieve what
all the previous kings of England had
failed to anyway cromwell's rule was
marred with financial problems and it
also saw the Commonwealth dragged into
numerous Wars the first was the first
anglo-dutch war in 1652 which started
because of the 1651 navigation Act which
prevented English colonies in North
America from trading with foreign States
long story short the Dutch lost but very
little changed this wasn't to be
Cromwell's last foreign war since in
1654 war broke out with Spain in the end
the Commonwealth seized Jamaica in the
Cayman Islands in the Caribbean as well
as Dunkirk in Europe
back in England Cromwell was struggling
with his new regime in 1657 after a
failed period of direct military rule a
new constitution was passed and Cromwell
was offered the crown which he declined
resistance to his rule was starting to
grow and so he had to resort to much
fiercer tactics to get what he wanted
this included taxing without the consent
of parliament and throwing those who
disagreed with him in prison without
trial of course he could do nothing
about those who disagreed with him
outside of England such as Thomas Hobbes
who whilst living in France wrote his
magnum opus Leviathan this was a defence
of absolute monarchy like that in France
and condemned the concept of a republic
chromos troubles came to an end in 1658
because he died the title of Lord
Protector passed to his son Richard
Cromwell because again it was nothing
like a monarchy basically no-one wanted
Richard
- rollin in 1659 he resigned in the rump
Parliament returned to run the country
thistle went to hell pretty quickly and
it looked like another civil war was
brewing so general monk marched down
south once in London he reinstated all
of the members of parliament who had
been ousted in prides purge in 1660
Parliament the same one that had been in
session since 1642 dissolved itself
hence white is known as the Long
Parliament during this time monk had
been in contact with Charles who issued
what was called the Declaration of Breda
for giving everything that happens in
1649 so long as the people there
accepted him as their king the exception
to this forgiveness was of course those
who signed his father's death warrant
the new parliament was summoned called
the convention Parliament which
acknowledged towers as Charles ii of
England and their rightful king in May
of 1660 Charles returned ending the
Commonwealth and England's Republican
experiment I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching and a
special thanks to James Bissonnette sol
invictus and dante of Livonia for
supporting the channel if you'd like to
know more about the English Civil War in
the Commonwealth period then there are
some book recommendations in the
description below